Hey
you
Oh
let's all be unified one single course
of Puppets for one single clause and
folder I've watched the local ABC NBC
CBS affiliates I even monitor Fox until
I get watch CNN and more often than not
not across the board but more often than
not they'll say and we spoke to one of
the protesters and then they put the
microphone in the face of the naked man
in the barrel or the girl on the stilt I
marry a guy in Austin let's work
together all the tyrants let's work
together go over to all the tyrants
there should be a signed it just said
slight question that should be there
should be a sign that says question
clapping every yeah this is about it
really pop question do you want to come
with a solution an answer they don't
even know because they're not asking the
right question what's their unified
message what's their demand
what's their
there is none right now there is none
right now shotgun shot and choice on
ceremoniously and toss on ceremony
Bostonians win it's a gathering of very
very frustrated very well-intentioned
good people thoughtful people who don't
know what else to do why are we still in
the middlee I'll tell you what he'll
tell you I Oh
it's a public movement
like girl how are you big Ivan Drago can
all [ __ ] but there are places that have
made no European socialism or communism
if you want to use that word it has
worked it's proven to be better really
because people think it's communism
living on Marion see if that's the case
well I don't have a conscience I don't
have a network I don't know if you go to
counter than William and are these are
these pins are they physically free
I have
which is a pape in
are you part of the movement for these
young guns cover the spirited annoying
honestly gun okay Youngblood has a
clembot Youngblood but you happy I'm
Jean the military office you're actually
you know can actually I believe I'm sure
oh thank you man so I gave you burn me
thank you very much let me get a [ __ ] in
that case go go get shot the case that's
funny that's good
don't make it a problem charger [ __ ] out
okay
that's a different thing don't make me
kill because you ain't got
you know how much is people making here
a lot more than that they make millions
of dollars a advice because they went to
school they went to prestigious schools
they come to me they got I'd really bad
when I couldn't eat this is Mike I come
from often I went to school I went to I
went to ACC I went to Austin Community
College because I put the pork and Adam
1.9 we all eat together
two dollars
charge
without passion question you work in the
tour guide why because I want to make
money and provide for myself to make a
living yeah but he asked more questions
yeah it's not the right question is not
the right question
takes strength from every fiber of my
being
when somebody says hey man I really like
your shirt it's really cool
I mean it's not to my unite vote I can
move everybody here control really means
your - yeah obviously you guys looking
for you Gaza today 2008 value more but
the reason why I'm talking you went to
propane charge me for labor Epson
charges beat the game on and troubles me
electricity and then the taxes for a
year pay the 225 to get corn in some way
to get down
the poor that's expensive yeah I know I
know a lie to me I didn't mean to be
rude North Korea Venezuela Cuba even
China to something like that what you
want to see the country these at a much
deeper movie review about you see I
answer to my question you're asking
games by more than a relic where people
that can get other questions people that
can get health care
okay ridiculous blocking River which may
be somewhere hippies you know I don't
think a person should human the only
please keep your voices down before
Saturday do you want to stay out of my
tent
what and push me out of my town of
course yet you quit what happened your
family they robbed me three times
who are you no animal to their mind
occupied you and but should there a
garage somewhere there's not
billionaires and Eagle Apple to know you
try to tell some weird results argue not
bad you can't be in my bias or your kid
boy Robbie is your job you trying to put
Oh